[Music]
I don't have you I'm gonna hear about it
later so here we go yeah thank you it's
awesome
hi everybody muscular wait yes look them
okay
wiry yes Fitness is boring I know I'm
sorry
it's going to do it's going to watch and
as gamers we deserve better today we are
really proud to announce a partnership
with Microsoft to bring a new type of
training on Xbox one
this November your workout will finally
become an epic game your personal
program an exciting quest and your coach
will train you for the ultimate bus
fight welcome to a new era of fitness
games we shape up we took the key
Fitness moves that ensure a good workout
and we transform each one of them into
an exciting challenge you would sprint
on the roof of a train you will lift the
defense even lunch asteroids because we
can prove that you will do more crunches
more push-ups and even more squats if
your workout becomes a game for us
Morphin means better results and I know
gamers watching might feel a little
skeptical about that but I once tried to
beat my high score on a coffee maker so
I feel like if I came for thinks they
can win at something they're gonna go
hard
sure so well let's see it cool let's
make we will show you two changes today
first channel step
we wanted to transform a cardio workout
a game that's me here by the way that's
me next to me I told you he was wiring
that's what we call the replay feature
it allows you to record every
performance save it for later send it to
your friend as today I will try to beat
my own best call let's try let's see if
I can teach me a good lesson this is
gonna be awesome
let me warm up okay that's me on this
side that's me this morning let's see
what you got Shani
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see you be himself oh well done
I'm already in a bit of [ __ ] that this
morning in your face sorry from the past
that was super fun now it's great to
walk you and a little weird but mostly
fun so we're gonna let Shapley catches
breath and we're gonna bring out a
couple of brave gamers for a little
healthy versus and so since Ubisoft
roots are obviously an unapologetically
french we're gonna engage in some good
old-fashioned stereotyping pitting a
couple of ubisoft employees against each
other the u.s. against the france
against the France that's what they
called it Les Halles
so first up on the red team we have the
pride of America he's American his light
beer deep-fried Oreos and catfish
noodling with that everybody give it up
for Gary from Ubisoft different Cisco
home of wheatgrass juice and six gear
bikes and ale a paha on the blue team we
have less way the false
he loves leisurely three-hour coffee
breaks making fun of American turrets
and playing football with his feet oh
welcome you give it up for just down
welcome guys you are here today to
represent your country for push-up
contests to the death but the more
push-up you will do the bigger the
object will be on your back that's the
game let's see who gets to the a-sun
first let's play your country is
watching
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was really the risotto it's clear
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody come to see us tomorrow at the
booth we are more challenges to try you
will be able to try to beat me I'm my
own best cause I have a great dish we
have fun thank you I thank you give it
up for Saffy
[Music]